this was coventry hospital at the peak
of the pandemic hospitals in england
were then admitting over 4 000 patients
a day
that number could be dwarfed this winter
according to government scientists who
have
their worst case scenario we've seen a
steady rise over recent weeks although
it has plateaued over recent days
the chief executive of coventry hospital
professor andy hardy told me those
numbers can't be ignored
but he's confident
his hospitals can cope with more
patients than in previous waves
it's fair to say that uh all of us are
always concerned about every winter that
comes up what we all do in the health
service is
you know we
we plan and prepare for the worst and
hope for the best we're expecting a
tough winter um but whatever comes our
way we intend to deal with it right now
the nhs is admitting around 1 000 new
covered patients each day that's much
higher than at this time last year they
peaked at around four and a half
thousand in january in 2021. the latest
modeling says admissions could rise to
between two and seven thousand this year
cases are increasing hospitalizations
are increasing
professor ko is a member of spymo the
panel of scientists that produced this
modeling
you have been wrong in the past
kind of projection that you have is
never going to be an exact crystal ball
so no matter what happens we always need
to plan on the basis of what we think
may happen now what we think may happen
can always be wrong the health secretary
said previous modeling predictions had
not come true but accepts some
mitigation measures may be needed
what happens in the nhs is going to be
hugely important to me to the whole
country making sure that we don't get to
a position again where the nhs becomes
unsustainable of course that would be
the level of hospitalization it will be
the pressures on a e the pressures on
the workforce so we'd have to take all
of these together
much has changed we have the vaccine and
better pandemic preparedness
but this is our first winter with the
delta variant the only thing we can say
with any certainty is that this winter
is going to be tough
joshi sky news